well let's focus now on the situation in
ukraine we've of course been discussing
it this morning and there are reports
that russian forces had
bombed an art school in mario paul where
400 people were
sheltering according to the mayor of
maripo thousands of residents of the
battered city have been forcibly taken
to russia it does feel as if
the news coming out of that country is
just relentless at the minute and we can
speak now to one of those important
voices from ukraine we're joined by the
deputy prime minister ola stephanie
thank you so much for
being on the program we always thank
guests for coming on the show but we are
especially grateful to you we of course
can't say
where you are in ukraine for obvious
security reasons and but what can you
tell us and our viewers about the
reality of what's happening on the
ground
yeah indeed i'm here in ukraine on a
beautiful ukrainian land unfortunately
many cities and parts of ukraine are
under fire and nothing left from the
beauty we all just seen 25 days ago the
situation is growing more and more
severe as i've been telling for a
numerous time more than 15 days of this
resistance are the resistance of
ukrainian people ukrainian nations who
face severe attack basically russia has
committed nearly all possible war crimes
uh which the humanity has seen over the
second world war the number of civilian
victims is far
more than of those from the armed forces
of ukraine it is absolutely essential
that nobody is getting used to the war
with 10 we resist and we will go
stronger regardless any attempts of the
russian federation which has failed so
far in its majority
you say that the russia russians have
failed so far
but how much longer do you think ukraine
can withstand this
well uh
when we were saying about the enormous
bravery of ukrainian people ukrainian
nation ukrainian army and ukrainian
government uh it's something that we
would expect from the all
leaders around the world who's standing
for the values enshrined in the u.n
charter and that's why ukraine will
resist as long as it's needed to make
sure that no terror no massive murdering
no genocide is committed on this land in
the 21st century but it is absolutely
clear that an only ukrainian army and
only ukrainian president will not be
able to withstand it alone it's really
important that all political leaders
around the world from us to european
union and asia would stay united and
establish the anti-war coalition and
only these joint efforts will allow us
to prevent this massive genocide and
murdering in the 21st century so far
ukrainian president ukrainian army
leaves a space and a time for the world
leaders to get even more united and to
stop this aggression we will stand as
much as it needed
so you believe it is a genocide
i absolutely believe it and i'm a lawyer
myself and i commit myself to
implementation of the decisions and
recently international court of justice
national court of justice has issued a
very concrete ruling uh on the case of
genocide russian federation against
ukrainian population and it has obliged
russian federation to suspend military
operation and refrain from any military
activity on our land
we know that the words and the rulings
and the orders mean nothing to the
russian federation but it's not
something i presume or anybody else
presumes this is the reality putin and
kremlin are the war criminals they
commit the war crimes and they do the
targeted attempts to attack ukrainian
population and you see it by the wording
on the net dilatification he's using so
uh it's not a question it's it's simply
the reality we all face in the 21st
century
another reality um a group of ukrainian
mps came to the british parliament this
week and they were speaking about what's
happening to women and girls in ukraine
and saying that they were being raped
and then executed by russian soldiers i
mean it almost feels too terrible to
talk about but it feels very important
to talk about what are you hearing about
what is happening to women and girls in
ukraine
you know in ukrainian government i used
to before the war uh run the file
related to gender equality and women
empowerment and of course the first five
days of war the horrible stories of
women's have heard but those women has
been raped for four hours and then
murdered about the mans and children who
have been killed the hospital druid
my tears were topless but now i have the
very strong aggression to make sure that
each and every military criminal who has
committed this crime is held to account
that's why
we have more than 2 000 cases criminal
cases opened in our prosecutor's office
we have the permanent information of the
international red cross organization and
each and every soldier who has committed
this war crime by order or not will be
held accountable be sure russian
soldiers that we fix and see it all and
ukrainian women will stand for each
other and we will prevail
it's incredibly inspiring to hear you
talk like this it really is um
president zelensky has told putin that
now is the time to talk
how hopeful are you that there could be
some kind of agreement some kind of
diplomatic solution
well it's not it it is definitely not
the talking between a brotherhood nation
or a bigger smaller brother uh ukraine
is feeling absolutely open to any kind
of thought because we stand on our
values we are backed up by each and
every nation of ukraine each and every
citizen of ukraine and we're united as
never before so uh these talks may take
place hopefully they will lead us to
some result we're extremely happy that
many of the uh european nations like
turkey like israel and and transatlantic
nations like israel and other countries
has um
initiated and will show the willingness
to facilitate this dialogue of course we
utilize all of these opportunities and
jointly i'm sure that ukraine uh will
reach the agreement uh on the peaceful
settlement but also will be uh
the country who have the guarantees of
his security solid clear and very well
uh understood to everybody guarantees of
his security not only from russian
federation but from other countries who
has the word to stay in uh in that
situation
what could an agreement look like it
feels as if there could be some movement
on nato
would ukraine be prepared to give up
some territory to russia
uh absolutely not uh ukrainian territory
is a territory which has been fixed into
in 1991 within its entirety and
internationally recognized buddha it's
not only the position of ukraine it's
the position of the whole world
enshrined in the numerous decisions of
the u.n security council including
security council where the russia is was
standing so it's not an option for
discussion of course there might be a
room for discussion on the reintegration
of those 10 territories has been under
occupation for the last eight years a
while uh there are like a number of the
red lines which are uh the
inexplicability to legitimize anyhow the
unlawful and provoked military
aggression on our territory this is the
red line for us and uh speaking of nato
uh as i'm leading the nato file in the
ukrainian government i can say that the
the feeling and the uh the political
priority is still there while the
ultimate element of the agenda today is
the is the ceasefire and the security
guarantee so far nato has not suggested
anything uh in the first and the second
uh element of this news from our side so
that's why we're looking for those
options which will ensure our security
and withdrawal of russian forces from
our territory thank you that's very
clear and just finally we've been
hearing some
horrific reports coming out of mario
paul and
shelters being bombed the mayor says
that
citizens are being forcibly removed and
taken to russia
what can you tell us about what is
happening in mario paul
uh mariupol is basically the the
forepost of all the tragedy and
sufferings our people are facing right
now it's already for the 10th day when
the ukrainian government with the
support of the icrc the red cross
organization and uh trying to facilitate
this process while russians have tried
to legitimize the evocation of ukrainian
people to russia and belarus through
international organization where they
were blocked and it has been um
recognized and absolutely a nonsense to
evocate people to the territory of the
country who has started the aggression
on ukrainian territory so now they do it
forcefully uh
reaching the the level of people
suffering to the to the way that they
are ready to get evocated everywhere
just to stay more or less out of this
bombing and the threat of their life is
less of course we call on standing on
the official information official uh
sources of information from the un icrc
ukrainian government who provide the
data on the agreed route for evocation
for ukrainian citizens who provide the
humanitarian assistance please ukrainian
people the people of europe stand with
us stand for the rule of law and do not
be subjected to manipulations from
russian
federation thank you so much for being
on the show and before we leave i just
want to give you the opportunity if
there's anything else that you would
like to say to western leaders um
you're the voice of ukraine for us this
morning so what would your message be
my message would be that uh be as brave
as ukrainians
and utilize each and every minute of
your time while we're keeping the the
peace on your land to make sure that the
aggressor and the terrorist is stopped
we deserve it as a nation we deserve it
as a people and we all deserve it as a
europe
thank you so much for being on the
program this morning you're an
incredibly powerful voice for your
country so it's been very important to
listen to thank you